major breaking news last night
and that is that the january 6th
committee investigating the trump riots
has now laid out in clear terms
the possible criminal charges against
donald trump now remember they can't
bring criminal charges these are members
of the house they have investigative
powers it is up to the justice
department currently guided by attorney
general merrick garland to decide are we
bringing criminal charges or not but
there was this open question for a very
long time
would the investigation
point to criminal charges against donald
trump and the answer now is yes and of
course the the million-dollar question
is
is there a prosecutor willing
to bring charges against a former
president so we'll start with a new york
times article january 6th committee
lays out potential criminal charges
against trump in a court filing the
panel said there was enough evidence to
suggest
trump might have engaged in a criminal
conspiracy as he fought to remain in
office
these are are such strange times where
outrageous things are normalized
things that would have been unthinkable
at times past five of them happen in a
week and we just kind of don't react
this is not normal
this is a really big deal not only is
there a committee investigating riots
incited by a former president desperate
to keep his grip on power on january 6
2021
but they believe that he may have
engaged in criminal conspiracy
the house committee investigating the
riots
said there is enough evidence to
conclude
former president donald trump and some
of his allies might have conspired to
commit fraud
and obstruction by misleading americans
about the outcome of the election and
attempting to overturn the result this
is a big big deal
in a court filing in a civil case in
california the committee's lawyers for
the first time
laid out their theory of a potential
criminal case against donald trump
they said they had accumulated evidence
demonstrating that trump
the conservative lawyer john eastman and
other allies could potentially be
charged with criminal violations
including obstructing an official
proceeding of congress and conspiracy to
defraud the american people
the filing also said the men might have
broken a common law statute against
fraud
through trump's repeated lies that the
election had been stolen
had been stolen
the filing disclosed only limited new
evidence the committee asked the judge
in the civil case to review the material
behind closed doors
this is
insane
in asserting the potential for
criminality the committee largely relied
on the extensive and detailed accounts
already made public of the actions trump
and his allies took to keep him in
office after defeat
cbs reporting house january 6 committee
says it has evidence trump and allies
engaged in quote criminal conspiracy
the house select committee investigating
the riots said in a court filing it has
evidence trump and allies engaged in a
criminal conspiracy by trying to block
congress from certifying the election
this is the first time the committee has
laid out a potential criminal case
against donald trump
this is a significant moment in the
investigation because it includes rare
disclosure of findings excerpts from
depositions and interviews with
witnesses including mike pence's top
advisor former justice department
leaders and those close to trump
newsweek
donald trump could face criminal charges
after explosive john eastman emails
revealed remember john eastman's this
lawyer who laid out what
a theoretical framework for trying to
flip the results of the election
this is not normal but and i know i'm
getting now dozens of emails and
voicemails from viewers and listeners
every day david do you still think trump
won't go to prison
yes
yes i do
and
people who say david when you say that
it makes it less likely he will go to
prison no i'm a random guy with a
microphone
nobody no potential prosecutor cares
what i am saying it doesn't make any
difference we have a situation here
where think of the steps first there has
to be some prosecutor willing to be the
first to charge donald trump a former
president that already takes a lot and
it doesn't seem merrick garland is going
to be that guy
we've talked about southern district of
new york we've talked about manhattan
district attorney we've talked about
georgia are any of these prosecutors
willing to be the first i don't deny
that if one prosecutor filed charges
moore would fall i i believe there would
i believe that there's many prosecutors
willing to be the second prosecutor or
the third prosecutor to file charges
against trump i'm not seeing any
evidence anyone is willing to be the
first if you did see that
in almost
99
of these types of cases you don't get a
trial
you get some kind of a plea you get
charges being dropped because things get
complicated etc if you get a trial you
don't necessarily get a guilty verdict
if you get a guilty verdict you almost
certainly don't get prison time so
think about the number of steps here so
yes if you want my opinion and that's
all it is i don't think trump does a day
in prison will we see charges at some
point maybe that's far more likely than
prison time but that is still my belief
at this point in time if you disagree
with me let me know i want to introduce
you to emmy the world's first instant
ramen that is low carb high protein and
100
plant-based
each serving of imi is packed with 21
grams of protein
19 grams of fiber has only five net
carbs works for keto diets and 35
percent less sodium than traditional
ramen brands i've been making it at home
just like any instant ramen it's ready
in just a few minutes you can use the
microwave you can use the stovetop you
really can't beat the convenience but
with imme you can feel good about the
ramen you're eating because of all the
fiber the lower sodium and it is
plant-based which i love even though i'm
not vegan or vegetarian but the best
part is
it's so well packaged it comes in
flavors like spicy beef
tom yum shrimp
black garlic chicken the taste and the
quality of the ingredients really sets
it apart from any other instant ramen
i've had and emmy is giving my audience
five dollars off a variety pack when you
go to emmyeats.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
the link is down below